Tom Hollands spider-man journey has
ended for now as he and jake gyllenhaal
just wrapped their tour in asia but
before that Tom Jake and zendaya were
stateside helping to spread some
superhero smiles to kids in need
hey guys what's up we are Children's
Hospital Los Angeles and we are about to
surprise some of the patients here
watching spider-man far from home
this is melting our hearts the gang
spent time with a group of very special
kids last week doing backflips signing
autographs and treating their young fans
to an advanced screening of the movie it
was just a wonderful afternoon and it's
lovely to see the smiles on their faces
those of you I mean they all know
spider-man and those of you don't know
Mysterio just to see them look at the
lights on my my Sierra's really cool
it's just think it's wonderful these
kids is so nice we got to put a smile on
their face and on their parents and
stuff and if we can do that then we
should you like how to shoot the webs
well I actually use all the webs on my
way over here your friendly neighborhood
spider-man has a habit of doing good
deeds Tom visited the kids at Children's
Hospital back when spider-man homecoming
hit theaters two years ago we're given
such an amazing opportunity making these
movies and we're so lucky to be doing it
we'd be doing something wrong if we
weren't giving back to our community
yeah spider-man far from home hits
theatres today and is expected to take
in around 500 million dollars over the
next 10 days you gonna be a next Iron
Man now well no I don't have time too
busy doing your job oh I'm kidding I'm
kidding look keep up the good work
because I am going on vacation
so why is this 23rd film set in the
Marvel Universe expected to be so
popular we've got a few reasons I'm just
a friendly neighborhood spider-man sir
please you've been to space first the
varville factor the Marvel films have
made more at the box office than the
Star Wars and Harry Potter movies
combined and spider-man is one of the
most beloved characters ever and Tom
Hollands fanbase just keeps growing it's
a dream come true in the job that keeps
on giving thank you so much for coming
guys thank you
the charming 23 year old Brett was
destined to play spider-man not only did
he do most of his own stunts in the
movie he's been doing his own stunts
since he was a baby
another reason we can't wait jake
gyllenhaal playing the mysterious and
aptly named Mysterio everyone was
excited about Jake joining the cast he
is a great guy and I've really looked up
to him oh you guys do have sarcasm on
this earth right and the third reason
this movie's a must-see you don't need
to see the rest of the Marvel movies to
enjoy it it catches you up in the first
five minutes and never turns back it's
got lots of laughs and a twist that will
leave you floored our spidey senses are
tingling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]